I want to thank mr. Collins mr. Naylor
for putting this together but as I sit
here today I can't help but think behind
me a filled room of 911 first responders
and in front of me a nearly empty
Congress sick and dying they brought
themselves down here to speak to no one
it's shameful it's an embarrassment to
the country and it is a stain on this
institution and you should be ashamed of
yourselves for those that aren't here
but you won't be because accountability
doesn't appear to be something that
occurs in this chamber the official FDNY
response time the 911 was five seconds
five seconds that's how long it took for
FDNY for NYPD for Port Authority for EMS
to respond to an urgent need from the
public five seconds
hundreds died in an instant
thousands more poured in to continue to
fight for their brothers and sisters the
breathing problem started almost
immediately and they were told they
weren't sick they were crazy and then as
the illnesses got worse and things
became more apparent well okay you're
sick but it's not from the pile and then
when the science became irrefutable okay
it's the pile but this is a New York
issue
no if we have the money and I'm sorry if
I sound angry and undiplomatic but I'm
angry and you should be too and they're
all angry as well and they have every
justification to be that way
there is not a person here there is not
an empty chair on that stage that didn't
tweet out never forget the heroes of
9/11 never forget their bravery never
forget what they did what they gave to
this country well here they are and
where are they they responded in five
seconds they did their jobs with courage
grace tenacity humility 18 years later
to yours thank you
[Applause]